and the sons of noah that went forth of
the ark were shem and ham and Japheth
and ham is the father of canaan these
are the three sons of Noah and of them
was the whole earth overspread and Noah
began to be a husbandman and he planted
a vine yard and he drank of the wine and
was drunken and he was uncovered within
his tent and ham the father of Canaan
saw the nakedness of his father and told
his two brethren without pen Shem and
Japheth took a garment and laid upon
both their shoulders and went backward
and covered the nakedness of their
father and their faces were backward and
they saw not their fathers nakedness and
Noah awoke from his wine and knew what
his younger son had done unto him and he
said curse had to be Canaan a servant of
servants shall he be unto his brethren
and he said blessed shall be the Lord
God of Shem and Canaan shall be his
servant and God shall enlarge Japheth
and he shall dwell in the tents of Shem
and Canaan shall be his servant and Noah
lived after the flood three hundred and
fifty years and all the days of Noah
were 950 years and he died and the whole
earth was of one language and of one
speech okay so I remember thinking about
this story it's got to be 30 years ago
and I think the meaning of the story
stood out for me sometimes when you read
complicated material sometimes a piece
of it will stand out it's for some
reason it's like it glitters I suppose
that might be one way of thinking about
it it's it you're in sync with it and
you can understand what it means I've
really experienced that reading the DAO
de Jing which is a document I would
really like to do a lecture on at some
point because some of the verses I don't
understand but others stand right out
and I can understand them and I think I
understood what this part of the story
of Noah meant and I think it means you
know we talked a little bit about what
nakedness meant in the story of Adam and
Eve and the idea essentially was that to
know yourself naked is to become aware
of your vulnerability the physical your
physical boundaries in time and space
and your your your physiological your
fundamental physiological
insufficiencies as they may might be
judged by others so there's biological
insufficiency that sort of built into
you because you're a fragile mortal
vulnerable half insane creature and
that's that's just an existential truth
and then of course even merely as a
human being even with all those faults
there are faults that you have that are
particular to you that might be judged
harshly by the group well might be will
definitely be judged harshly by the
group and so to become aware of your
nakedness is to become self-conscious
and and to and to know your limits and
to know your vulnerability and that's
what is revealed to ham when he comes
across his father naked and so the
question is what does it mean to see
your father naked and it seems to me and
especially in an inappropriate manner
like this it it it's it's it's as if ham
he does the same thing that happens in
the Mesopotamian creation myth when when
time out and absolute give rise to the
first gods they're the father of the
eventual deity of redemption
Marduk they're very careless and noisy
and they kill apps ooh their father and
attempt to inhabit his corpse and that
makes timeout enraged and so she bursts
forth from the darkness to to do them in
it's like a precursor to the flood story
or an analogue to the flood story and I
see the same thing happening here with
ham is that he's he's insufficiently
respectful of his father and the
question is exactly what does the father
represent and you can say well there's
there's there's the father that you have
and that's a human being that's a man
like other men a man among men but then
there's the farther as such and that's
the spirit of the Father and insofar as
you have a father you have both at the
same time you have the personal father
that's a man among other men just like
any one other's father but insofar as
that man is your father that means that
he's something different than just
another person
and what he is is the incarnation of the
spirit of the Father and to see that to
take it to what to disrespect that
carelessly maybe even he's like no one
makes a mistake right he produces wine
and gets himself drunk and you might say
well you know if he sprawled out there
for everyone to see it's hardly hams
fault if he stumbles across them but the
book is laying out a danger and the
danger is that well maybe you catch your
father at his most vulnerable moment and
if you're disrespectful
then you transgress against the spirit
of the father and if you transgress
against the spirit of father and lose
spirit of the Father and lose respect
for the spirit of the father then that
is likely to transform you into a slave
that's a very interesting idea and I
think it's particularly interesting
maybe not particularly interesting but
it's it's particularly germane I think
to our current cultural situation
because I think that we're pushed
constantly to see the nakedness of our
Father so to speak because of the
intense criticism that's directed
towards our culture and the patriarch of
culture so to speak we're constantly
exposing its weaknesses and
vulnerabilities and let's say nakedness
and there's nothing wrong with criticism
but the thing about criticism is the
purpose of criticism is to separate the
wheat from the chaff it's not to burn
everything to the ground right it's to
say well we're going to carefully look
at this we're going to carefully
differentiate we're going to keep what's
good and we're going to move away from
what's bad but the point of the
criticism isn't to identify everything
is bad it's to separate what's good from
what's bad so that you can retain what's
good and move towards it and and to be
careless at that is deadly because
you're inhabited by the spirit of the
Father right and so far as you're a
cultural construction which of course is
something that the that the postmodern
neo-marxists are absolutely emphatic
about you're a cultural construction
insofar as you're a cultural
construction then you're inhabited by
the spirit of the Father and to be
respectful towards that means to
undermine the very structure that makes
you not all of what you are certainly
certainly not all of what you are but a
good portion of what you are insofar as
you're a socialized cultural entity and
if you pull out if you pull the
foundation out from underneath that what
do you have left
you can hardly manage on your own you
know it's just not possible
you're a cultural creation and so Pam
makes this desperate error and is
careless about exposing himself to the
vulnerability of his father something
like that he doesn't without sufficient
respect and the judgment is that not
only will he be a slave but so all of
his descendants and he's contrasted with
the other two sons who I suppose are
willing to give their father the benefit
of the doubt something like that
and so when they see him in a
compromising position they handle it
with respect and and and don't
capitalize on it and maybe that makes
them strong that's what it seems to me
and so I think that's what that story
means it has something to do with
respect you know and the funny thing
about having respect for your culture
and I suppose that's partly why I'm
doing the biblical stories is because
they're part of our they're part of my
culture they're part of our culture
perhaps but they're certainly part of my
culture and it seems to me that it's
worthwhile to treat that with respect to
see what you can glean from it and and
not kick it when it's down let's say so
and so that's how the story of Noah ends
you know and the thing too is Noah is
actually a pretty decent incarnation of
the spirit of the Father that which I
suppose is one of the things that makes
hams misstep more egregious is that I
mean Noah just built an ark and got
everybody through the flood man you know
it's not so bad and so maybe the fact
that he happened to drink too much wine
one day wasn't enough to justify
humiliating him and you know I don't
think it's pushing the limits of
symbolic interpretation to note on a
daily basis that we're all contained in
an ark right and that's the ark that you
could think about that as the Ark that's
being bequeathed to us by our
forefathers that's the tremendous
infrastructure that we inhabit that we
take for granted because it works so
well that protects us from things that
we can't even imagine and we don't have
to imagine because we're so well
protected and so one of the things
that's really struck me hard I would say
about the disintegration and corruption
of the universities is the absolute
ingratitude that goes along with that
you know what
criticism as I said it's a fine thing if
it's done in the spirit in a proper
spirit and that's the spirit of
separating the wheat from the chaff but
it needs to be accompanied by gratitude
and it does seem to me that anyone who
lives in in the West in the West culture
at this time in history and in this
place and who isn't simultaneously
grateful for that is is half blind at
least because it's never been better
than this and it could be so much worse
and it's highly likely that it will be
so much worse because for most of human
history so much worse is the norm